for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out move
university comm thank you and enjoy so
when it comes to ketone bodies over
production of them over production of
ketone bodies is bad why is this well
because ketone bodies are acidic why is
that well we've already shown what the
ketone bodies look like with
acetoacetate d beta hydroxy butyrate
here though the way I've drawn them is
in their conjugate base form right in
their acid form right they're protonated
form there Osito acetic acid and d beta
hydroxy butyric acid right they end an 8
here because they are the conjugate
bases but when they are protonated when
they have that hydrogen there that could
donate that hydrogen right because they
are acids and when they donate that
proton to an environment they acidify
the environment that they're in so what
can happen is that ketone bodies can
build up in the blood ok
and so ketone body build up that's
called ketosis
okay now ketone bodies being acidic they
build up in the blood
they will acidify the blood they will
decrease the pH of the blood right
making it more acidic
that's called acidosis and that is
really bad that's potentially fatal
right that can kill people okay now so a
decrease in the pH of the blood that's
acidosis
ketone body build-up that's ketosis now
a decrease in the pH of the blood due
specifically the ketone bodies building
up that's called keto acid dosis right
just a combination of ketosis and
acidosis okay now when does it occur
well two cases that I'm going to bring
up our starvation and type 1 diabetes
let's start with starvation during
starvation basically what's going on is
that's an extended fast not
eating for a very long time and during
fasting periods your body depends on fat
stores for energy now during starvation
it's not just the fast you're not just
depending on fat stores body also begins
the tap on muscle protein for energy as
well but I won't get to that the point
is though that during starvation we're
depending to a great extent on fat
source for energy so our body breaks
down triglycerides into glycerol and
fatty acids and we can break down those
fatty acids so fatty acids here in the
mitochondrial matrix of a hepatocyte I
realize now that writing liver
hepatocyte is kind of redundant but
we've got fatty acids in the
mitochondrial matrix we're gonna break
them down to a bunch of acetyl co ways
right and of course that's going to be
via beta oxidation right so during
starvation that's going to occur a great
deal also during starvation we're not
taking in food right someone's starving
they have no carbohydrate intake no
glucose right so their body responds by
increasing gluconeogenesis okay and when
this happens when we have an increase in
gluconeogenesis making glucose what
happens is that oxaloacetate
in medical and rio matrix will basically
make its way out into the cytosol in
order to be part of gluconeogenesis so
here we've got oxaloacetate and it's
going to make its way out front of the
mitochondrial matrix into the cytosol
via male eight right it's going to go as
male 8 it's not going to go as
oxaloacetate and it's going to go out
into the cytosol to basically make
glucose via gluconeogenesis which I'll
write here so what's the consequence of
that well if this oxaloacetate is
leaving what that means is that it's not
available to join with acetyl co a in
the first step of the krebs cycle right
which forms
situate men citrate synthase reaction so
that's not going to happen and so
basically what happens is that acetyl co
a is left hanging right it's left alone
without its buddy oxaloacetate to go to
the krebs cycle so it builds up in the
mitochondrial matrix acetyl co a will
build up in the matrix because it's not
flowing to the Krebs cycle and so it's
got to go somewhere this acetyl co a is
activated it's got to go
so that acetyl co a instead goes through
ketone body synthesis or ketogenesis
alright so I'll write that here keto
Genesis and it'll go to producing ketone
bodies and so what will happen is that
these ketone bodies will then be sent
out of the cell into the blood and then
to the extra hepatic tissues right now
those tissues of course will use them
for energy but during starvation this is
going to happen to a great extent
because the body is depending on these
fatty acids right so it's going to be
producing a bunch of acetyl co a and I
should emphasize this bunch obviously
look away so if we have a lot of acetyl
co a we're going to have a lot of ketone
bodies right a bunch of this a bunch of
those so if we have a bunch of those
basically we're supplying ketone bodies
to these tissues to these extra hepatic
tissues right and those tissues are not
going to be oxidizing the ketone bodies
at a rate that's keeping up with the
supply right the supply of ketone body
so it's what's going to happen is that a
lot of those ketone bodies are just
going to hang out in the blood because
they're not being oxidized by the
tissues and so we've got a buildup of
the ketone bodies in the blood and that
is basically keto acid OSIS alright so
that that can happen during starvation
okay that's obviously really bad that's
part of the reason people can starve to
death
right can starve to death specifically
right
ah so that's what starvation what's
going on with type 1 diabetes it's
actually not too different okay um it's
just the different sort of cause right
and I'll get into that right now
type 1 diabetes type 1 diabetics have
insufficient insulin and insulin is
supposed to take up glucose from the
blood right when the blood glucose Rises
insulin triggers it to be taken up by
the cells out of the blood but type 1
diabetics either have very little
insulin or not at all and that's bad
because glucose cannot be taken up by
the cells and so the cells must make the
glucose and so what happens is that
gluconeogenesis is active so there's an
increase in gluconeogenesis and what
you'll notice here is that I have just a
bunch of these little arrows and the
reason why I have that is just an
indicator that basically since the cells
must have to make glucose basically it's
the same situation from here onward
right from here onward the same
situation happens in type 1 diabetes
that they do with starvation with
increasing gluconeogenesis causing the
oxaloacetate to make its way out into
the cytosol to basically be involved in
gluconeogenesis and then the acetyl co a
builds up in the matrix because it's not
flowing to the krebs cycle then the
acetyl co a goes through ketogenesis
ketone bodies build up and we have
ketoacidosis so the one key difference
is that it is caused by an insufficient
amount of insulin as opposed to not
having a carb intake right so this is
specifically called diabetic diabetic
ketoacidosis right it's still q2
acidosis it's still ketone bodies
building up in the blood and that's
going to of course acidify the blood and
that's really really bad but it's just
the cause right it's about a lack of
carb intake in starvation versus a lack
of the ability to uptake glucose in
diabetes right in fact for this reason
because of the similarity right
starvation and
type 1 diabetes I've heard of type type
type 1 diabetes being referred to as
starvation amongst plenty because the
glucose is there the body just can't use
it okay so um yeah that's basically what
happens
um ketoacidosis definitely not a cool
thing anyway I hope that video is
helpful thank you for watching if you
found that video helpful don't forget to
like comment subscribe and share with
friends thank you and happy studying